if you've seen beetlejuice about
167 times then once you finish this
video you're going to want to see it
168th time keep watching so it'll be
even funnier the next time you see it
while beetlejuice is all about ghosts
monsters death and other objectively
spooky stuff it's actually not all that
scary this is thanks to michael keaton's
delightfully hammy work and the non-stop
bits of comedy to keep things from
tipping into full bore horror as it
turns out all that stuff happened during
rewrites and filming in its earliest
conceptions beetlejuice was a very
different movie in michael mcdowell's
script the maitland's death scene is
quite graphic and traumatic after that
they enlist the help of beetlejuice who
isn't so much an edgy clown in stripes
as he is an evil demon with wings while
he attempts to simply scare away the new
residents of the maitland's old house in
the movie he pretty much tries to kill
them in the original draft his
relationship with lydia dietz is
especially predatory as the ghost tries
to get with her in a way that's even
more inappropriate than the final film
before he tears her apart portraying
beetlejuice was a surprising departure
from michael keaton a star who was at
that point previously known for his
regular guy roles in comedies like
gung-ho and mr mom his performance here
showed he was more than capable of
pulling off horror gonzo comedy and well
just about anything to reinforce that
immediately after beetlejuice director
tim burton cast him as bruce wayne in
batman you're welcome with a
professional here
burton is a quirky filmmaker who often
makes off-the-wall casting decisions
while keaton might have been a somewhat
surprising choice he actually wasn't
even burton's first pick for the title
role he initially wanted beloved actor
crooner candyman and all-around
entertainer sammy davis jr for the part
up to that point the script called for
the character to be a bit more evil with
a las vegas lounge singer kind of vibe
since davis was a former rat packer he
fit the bill in that last regard credit
for keaton's casting goes to producer
david geffen who talked burton out of
his pick and suggested he'd check out
the future dark knight instead you like
it
during burton and keaton's first meeting
the former tried his best to explain
beetlejuice's far out concept to his
eventual star and apparently he didn't
do such a great job of communicating his
admittedly outlandish ideas in a
conversation with charlie rose in 2014
keaton said i didn't understand what he
was talking about but i liked him i went
oh well this guy's something i said i i
wish i could do it you seem like a
really nice guy and i know you're
creative but i don't know what you're i
don't get it burton was able to convince
keaton to meet again and that time he
went into more detail about the project
the actors still didn't understand and
politely declined beetlejuice once more
undeterred burton persuaded him to take
a third meeting and this time he rattled
off some ideas that keaton said just
logged in his brain he asked burton for
some time to think it over which he
spent building the characters so he
could wrap his mind around it say it
once saying twice third time's a charm
keaton called up some associates at the
production studio's wardrobe house and
asked for various clothing choices from
different time periods he also requested
some help in creating the character's
appearance he wanted his hair to look
like he was shocked by an electrical
outlet in his face to have mold on it
all that stuff wound up in the
character's final design
tim burton wanted to call the movie
beetlejuice but he had to put up a bit
of a fight to make it happen as a young
filmmaker at the time burton had to deal
with a certain amount of studio
interference and executives initially
planned to give the movie the bland and
forgettable title house ghosts
he hated that idea so he tried to play a
little game with his bosses he suggested
the title scared sheetless instead
thinking the powers that be would relent
and let him go for beetlejuice but the
plan backfired the studio actually liked
scared sheetless and seriously
considered releasing the movie under
that title ultimately burton got his way
after threatening to hurl himself out a
window over 30 years later the role of
awkward teenage goth lydia dietz still
ranks among winona ryder's most
definitive and popular performances
beetlejuice launched a young actor into
mega stardom and marked her first
collaboration with tim burton with whom
she'd work again on edward scissorhands
and frankenweenie looking back it's hard
to believe that ryder just barely landed
the part and only landed it after
beating out an actor who doesn't seem
very burtonesque at all who's the boss
teen sensation alyssa milano i myself am
strange and unusual
in a 2016 interview with huff post live
milano revealed that casting for the
part of lydia came down to two choices
ryder and herself when reflecting on how
badly she wanted the part she said you
always wonder what would have happened
differently in my life had that worked
out not that i would want it to be any
different but it's just an interesting
thought game
burton helped kathryn o'hara's career
with beetlejuice and the movie had a
major effect on her off-screen life too
brooding mysterious odd these are words
one would use to describe tim burton but
probably not romantic or matchmaker
still according to o'hara he exercised
that part of his personality on the set
of beetlejuice bo welch served as the
movie set designer so he was very much
responsible for giving the film its
sensational and original postmodern
horror look and burton thought that he
and o'hara would make a very cute couple
so he tried to make it happen o'hara
told digital spy that tim actually set
us up to date if you don't let me gut
out this house and make it my own i will
go and stay and i will take you with me
they hit it off and a couple of years
later welch and o'hara got married and
had two children those kids owe their
lives to a casting switcheroo their
parents may never have met if o'hara
hadn't replaced angelica houston who won
the role of delia but had to drop out of
the project after she fell ill
one unexpected ripple effect of
beetlejuice it made calypso cool again
which hadn't been in the pop
consciousness much since harry belafonte
topped the charts in the 1950s and early
60s i didn't even know i could do the
calypso during a dinner party new
haunted house residents delia and
charles dietz and their guests become
compelled by ghostly forces to perform a
musical number set to deo that's just
one of multiple belafonte songs in the
movie in the opening minutes alec
baldwin's adam maitland listens to
sweetheart from venenzuela later lydia
joyfully dances and floats to jump in
the line shake senora and deo also plays
earlier in the film when gina davis's
barbara maitland peruses the handbook of
the recently deceased while adam works
on his model none of that appeared in
the first version of michael mcdowell's
screenplay when writer warren skarin
took a pass his draft included classic r
b the haunted dinner party scene
involved the humans dancing to the ink
spots if i didn't care and suggested
that lydia would provide a rendition of
when a man loves a woman where did the
calypso come from catherine o'hara
according to her on-screen husband
jeffrey jones o'hara suggested that the
musical forum would liven up the dinner
party scene tim burton and the rest of
the filmmaking team dug the idea so they
set about getting the rights to old
calypso tunes and threading them
throughout the movie
he's gone on to log numerous hits and
cult classics but beetlejuice might be
tim burton's signature movie all his
calling cards are present a ghoulish
protagonist a mixture of high comedy and
spooky darkness and quaint puppet and
model-based special effects in
beetlejuice our title character attempts
to terrify the deet's family out of the
former maitland home by rising up out of
a town model michael keaton appears
ghostly white mouth the gape and wearing
a mobile on his head that's comprised of
little dragons and hideous sea monsters
this mobile comes in the form of a black
and white striped tube hat to match his
primary costume and the top of the
umbrella-like contraption is overseen by
a little model of some kind of undead
creature that creature is a dead ringer
for jack skellington the main character
in burton's a nightmare before christmas
which wasn't released until five years
after beetlejuice
given how popular it remains the absence
of a sequel to beetlejuice is surprising
but it isn't for a lack of effort
shortly after the first film burton
created an outline that writer jonathan
jims turned into a script titled
beetlejuice goes hawaiian as jim's told
fangoria tim thought it would be funny
to match the surfing backdrop of a beach
movie with some sort of german
expressionism because they're totally
wrong together beetlejuice goes hawaiian
was publicly announced in 1990 with
michael keaton winona ryder catherine
o'hara and jeffrey jones all agreeing to
reprise their roles the story found the
characters heading to hawaii to check up
on diet's construction project a casino
built on top of a sacred hawaiian burial
ground along the way lydia visits the
worlds of the undead and beetlejuice
wins a surfing contest but then warner
brothers offered burton total creative
control on batman returns so he and
keaton went off to do that interest died
the actors moved on and the script was
never filmed nor was a subsequent effort
by beetlejuice co-writer warren skarin
called beetlejuice in love in which the
ghost with the most offers up his
services to some new characters in 2011
warner brothers decided to explore a
sequel once more with a script
potentially written by pride and
prejudice and zombies author seth graham
smith that never turned into cinematic
gold either however the beetlejuice
sequel has yet to find itself in the
lost souls rule efforts to bring a
second film to life continued and in
february of 2022 plan b a production
company founded by brad pitt jennifer
aniston and brad gray became involved
will beetlejuice 2 finally be
resurrected
only time will tell check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]